[Musique]
il
rien n'a changé depuis des millions
d'années
comme si le temps avait suspendu son
cours sous les feuillages de cette forêt
subtropicale
[Musique]
au milieu de cette végétation exubérante
l'homme se sent vite minuscule étrangers
imaginez qu'à chaque instant va surgir
un mail ou un dinosaure
ce monde perdu c'est la gomera dans
l'archipel des canaries une île
volcanique ou les cracheurs de feu tous
éteints ont laissé place à des plages de
sable noir et d'immenses ravin escarpé
notre voyage commence dans le sud
rocailleux où nous suivons nepad audrey
cette française tombée amoureuse de
l'île et guide à la gomera depuis sept
ans
toutes les îles canaries son désir
volcaniques qui n'ont jamais été
connectée au continent
labeaume ra environ 10 millions d'années
à cette époque ce sont des éruptions
successifs qui peu à peu ont fait sortir
l'île de l'atlantique
ce qu'on peut voir réussir ce sont les
différentes couches de magma par exemple
ça c'était une coulée de lave et couche
après couche petit à petit lille a
grandi
ici on sent vraiment la puissance de la
nature une nature vivante c'est et qui
restait intacte au fil des siècles
[Musique]
à tel point que sur cette île vivent
encore certains animaux tout droit sorti
de la préhistoire
ici se trouve à l'état naturel la seule
population au monde de lézards géants de
la gomera
il ne fait plus qu'une vingtaine
lorsqu'on les a découvert en 1999 et
aujourd'hui ils sont presque 300
le monstre de la gomera est en fait un
dragon miniatures
et celui ci laquelle âge
lui il doit avoir entre 10 et 11 ans ce
sont les seuls les arts au monde à avoir
la gorge blanche table
à l'âge adulte il atteint tout de même
les 30 cm d'espèces a frôlé l'extinction
mais grâce à ce centre de sauvegarde
elle est aujourd'hui hors de danger
il faut leur enlever les parasites
de temps en temps pour éviter qu'il ne
tombe malade
chaque année 60 à 100 les rg en est en
captivité certains des plus vigoureux
sont ensuite relâchés dans la nature
mais sur la gomera les reptiles ne sont
pas les seuls témoins des temps
préhistoriques
au coeur de l'île là où les sommets
s'élève jusqu'à 1500 mètres d'altitude
ces tentes une forêt primaire bélier par
un brouillard quasi permanent
cette forêt existe parce qu'elle se
trouve à une altitude très précises là
où passent les alizés qui apporte
beaucoup nous inviter les formes comme
une mer de nuages si on redescend on est
quasiment dans un 1er temps
procès miguel olano et professeur de
biologie alors ici il est un peu comme
un grand enfant dans une confiserie
aujourd'hui avec ce curieux instrument
il est venu récupérer des échantillons
d'arbres pour les étudier
on va pouvoir déterminer son âge et les
climats qu'il a connu cela demande alors
comment l'armement dans
le parc de gala rona y est inscrit au
patrimoine mondial
et bien qu'ils reçoivent chaque année
cinq cent mille visiteurs en moyenne
certaines zones sont strictement fermé
au public pour être préservé
pour s'y aventurer nous suivons
exceptionnellement jacinto les râles tas
il est guide du parc et connaît chaque
recoin et chaque secret de cette forêt
mais la regarder ça
c'est un fruit de vignes à tigo c'est
cet arbre gigantesque vous voyez juste
derrière est absolument que tout ça est
sorti d'une seule et même grain
ce sont en fait
les vieux arbres meurent les deux
nouvelles branches poussent ils avaient
mis la main
sur presque 4000 hectares le parc est un
sanctuaire pour des centaines d'espèces
aujourd'hui introuvable en europe
continentale elle incarne tué lana de
l'alena au challenge en dénoncer toute
cette nature c'est un sou dans le passé
dans les ferait qu il occupait notamment
la france durant l'ère tertiaire il ya
des millions d'années auparavant
la plupart de ces plantes
vendu qu'à l'état de fossiles autour de
la méditerranée mais ici elles sont
encore
s'ajouter au moins
bien vivant aussi les traditions
ancestrales qui ont fait la renommée de
lille
nous voici 10 km plus à l'ouest dans le
village d'el cirque à dos
ils adorent ça c'est l'heure des pauvres
on ne peut pas faire de la poterie avec
toutes les terres il faut qu'elle soit
là poissons et les résistants dans ce
massif
cette argile rouge et la signature des
potières de l'île de la gomera ici cet
art primitif se transmet entre femmes de
générations en générations
moi je fais ça depuis que je suis toute
petite comme ma mère travaillait déjà
dans cet atelier j'ai appris en la
regardant la neige est certaine cette
tactique était déjà utilisé à l'époque
par nos ancêtres aborigènes les tout
premiers habitants de la gomera radio
rom alors
carmen n'utilise pas de tour de potier
toutes ces pièces sont modelés à la main
et poli avec un simple galets
voilà c'était ça les outils des
aborigènes de se débrouiller avec peu de
choses
une fois cuit paul piché jarre se
retrouve sur les étagères de sa boutique
avec un certain succès
ça on s'en sert pour servir leur brio
une spécialité de l'ailé
mais vous pouvez aussi mettre des pommes
de terre du poisson ou la viande
on va prendre ces trois-là
la culture de chaque endroit doit être
préservé il faut la maintenir vivante et
pour cela il faut et va donner un petit
coup de main aux artisans
l'héritage de la gomera c'est aussi une
histoire faite de conquêtes direction
san sebastian une capitale aux allures
de village c'est ici que nous retrouvons
audrey notre guide française c'est aussi
là qu'a fait escale le plus illustre des
explorateurs
on surnomme la gomera life la colombie
n'a pas ce que saint paul on s'est
arrêté ici en 492 la gomera c'était le
dernier endroit où il pouvait s'arrêter
pour pouvoir s'approvisionner avant de
traverser l'océan n'y avait pas eu la
gomera le voyage aurait été probablement
impossible en fait
mais collomb est loin d'être le seul
navigateur à avoir compris l'intérêt
stratégique de la gomera
bonjour soyez les bienvenus le curé juan
alamos nous ouvre les portes de l'église
pour nous dévoiler son chef-d'oeuvre
ce n'est ni un vitrail ni une peinture
religieuse mais une fresque inattendu
représentant une bataille navale
ces bateaux étaient ceux de pirate
anglais il venait pour envahir l'île
les habitants étaient moins bien armés
et pourtant ils ont gagné la bataille
alors à cette époque tout le monde
pensait que c'était grâce à une
intervention divine elle c'est pour ça
qu'on a mis ce tableau dans les écoles
mais la victoire des gommes héros ne
relève pas uniquement du miracle les
habitants de l'île possédait un atout
décisif
aujourd'hui ce langage sifflet est
encore utilisée par les bergers comme
ramon
moi mon père m'appelait en sifflant
quand j'étais petit parfois je parte a
joué au beau milieu des montagnes mais
je l'entendais et je lui répondais rares
sont ceux à le comprendre certains les
surnomme les hommes oiseaux
moi mon père m'appelait en sifflant
quand j'étais petit parfois je partais
jouer au beau milieu des montagnes mais
je l'entendais et je lui répondais bon
et ça nous permet aussi de communiquer
entre nous sans que les étrangers ne
comprennent c'est très pratique pour
prévenir l'arrivée de la guardia civil
pour que la tradition ne se perdent pas
le symbo est un enseignement obligatoire
pour les yeux collier de la gomera
à toi et ça est maintenant
trop diane et professeurs elle nous
offre un petit cours particuliers
c'est faux que l'élève reçoit coller
autant comme une grand-mère est
patiente on vient à pied la langue qu'on
peut le doigt et j'aime la foule
inscrit depuis 2009 au patrimoine
immatériel de l'humanité le cil beau
imitent les sons de la langue orale
en fait il faut arriver à reproduire les
voyelles le haut et le hall sont g le
client est prévenu et le a et le e un
peu entre les deux
c'est maintenant l'écho des vagues qui
nous appelle nous quittons lille par
bateau direction la pointe nord le
dernier trésor de la gomera ne se
dévoilera que depuis l'océan et il se
mérite
bon maintenant on va passer juste à côté
des roches andy rhis bateaux
coulés
oui elles vont jamais et non je suis
toujours là aujourd'hui je touche du
bois
après une heure de traversée c'est une
merveilles géologiques qui apparaît
on les appelle les orgues tout
simplement parce qu'il ressemble aux
orgues des églises avec leurs tubes
verticaux
se font des coulées de lave qui ont
refroidi très lentement durant des
centaines d'années c'est ce qui explique
ses formes
une oeuvre éphémère car ces grandes
orgues et rodez peu à peu par l'océan et
la pluie finiront par disparaître
mais pas d'inquiétude nous avons encore
quelques milliers d'années pour profiter
de ces paysages fabuleux
[Musique]
plus